what if your passion is money so I got a
great question for one of my newsletter
readers love you guys Andrew who wrote
in to say hi Evan it's funny that you
send me this today as you know I'm a big
fan of your videos thank you Andrew what
if your passion is money what if
actually earning money is your passion
or do you think that this isn't possible
and money is an outcome from passion
I've been thinking about this for a
while now time regards Andrew and just a
great question and one that I either get
asked a lot or people are thinking a lot
money comes up so much I think a lot of
times because people just don't have
enough money right like you don't have
money to do the things that you want to
do in your life you're you're maybe
under crushing Devon you want a greater
lifestyle and and you see money as he
escaped right money is never the passion
okay at best money allows you to buy a
lifestyle allows you to buy freedom that
you don't have now what would you do
with the money right making the money is
not a passion what would you do you want
the result right you want to buy the car
the house the you want to pay for you
know medical treatment for your family
whatever it is you might have a really
burning desire to make more money but
there's a reason behind it but imagine a
world where you had this is a great
exercise they if you had the most money
in the world he had all the money you
need you could do whatever you wanted
you didn't have to worry about your
bills you didn't have to worry about if
you have a boss you don't worry about
your boss or wear anything you know the
money you need what do you do with your
life and at first I might say oh I
travel the world I would sit on the
beach and just sip pina coladas or
whatever but you know what that gets
boring man it gets born and you look at
people who've gone that route and
they've sold their businesses and make
tons of money and maybe they do they
travel for a year but honestly it gets
boring because that's not a sustainable
lifestyle that makes you happy you're
put on this earth for a reason you got
to find what your passion is and you
should want to leave the world in a
better place than what
it was when you came here the world
should be better for you having lived
here that's not going to be because you
made a lot of money nobody's going to
come to your funeral because they said
and you made a lot of money here's a
good example look at the people in the
world who've made the most money okay
look at look at the Forbes list of the
richest people in the world you look at
warren buffett look at Bill Gates look
at these guys who've made the most money
in the world okay Warren Buffett gave
away most of his fortune to charity Bill
Gates from microsoft created software
created a huge company and now left to
go run his own charity these people were
not motivated by money look at Steve
Jobs one of my favorite stories Steve
Jobs as a millionaire by the time he was
in his early 20s early twenty is
millionaire late 20s multi-millionaire
he had more money than then he ever
needed by his late 20s and yet he
continued to work every single day on
his business ideas he came back to Apple
and he worked until the day he died in
failing health he kept working on Apple
because it was important to him you look
at Apple he built the company that has
the largest market cap right it's the
most valuable company in the world and
Steve Jobs built this by not focusing on
the money you look at the guys who have
the most amount of money in the world
and their focus isn't just on making
money that's the difference the guys who
say their passion is just money they
never end up making a lot of money the
end up broke because they think their
passion is money you got to find your
calling and for for everybody it's
different but what it involves is
helping people you feel good when you're
helping somebody out when you know
you've helped somebody out of a jam when
you've used your resources your
knowledge your ideas to make somebody's
life better in some way that gets you
here that's something that's important
so you got to find out what that is and
for some people they know it they know
it easily and other
it's a journey take some time and if you
don't know it yet it sounds like you
don't and that's fine that's that's a
lot of people man that's a lot of people
just start experimenting think about the
things that make you happiest think
about the times that you're happiest and
go try some new things and see where you
can contribute and something I guarantee
you will fall if you're going into
something with an open mind you will
find your passion I mean I have a sukkah
guide that can walk you through
step-by-step how to find a business idea
that is your passion but it's not about
the money man I guarantee you the people
who say that just haven't found their
life's passion and I feel a little sad
because when you figure that out you'll
feel so much happier and the world would
be a much better place the world should
be a much better place because Andrew
Liang lived here now what do you do to
make that happen believe those you
watching i love to know what your
passion is leave it below get me to feel
something make me excited leave it in
the comments I'd love to hear from it
and you like this you to give it a
thumbs up below click on my face and
swear to the channel thank you so much
I'll see you soon